ja heute morgen um 6 uhr im schutz der
dunkelheit haben hier zwei busse geparkt
und wenige minuten später haben sich
polizisten einer spezialeinheit zugang
verschafft zu diesem eingang dieses
wohnblocks wenige minuten später hat man
gebrüll gehört geschrei gehört
wir sehen jetzt übrigens hinter uns sind
immer noch polizeibeamte in diesem
wohnblock in nord charlottenburg gesucht
wird hier ein deutscher staatsbürger der
in die kriminellen geschäfte involviert
sein soll
der wurde auch angetroffen ob er sich
jetzt zu diesem zeitpunkt noch in der
wohnung hier in berlin-charlottenburg
befindet dass es unklar er könnte
verhört werden jetzt in diesen minuten
welche rolle er allerdings spielt in den
kriminellen geschäften das ist noch
unklar
da einfach schön angelique für den
moment und wir wollen direkt weiter
schalten nach brandenburg zu unserem
kollegen hannes habig hannes kannst du
uns erzählen was wurde heute morgen bei
dir gemacht was wurde durchsucht wenige
minuten vor 7 uhr ist die polizei und
das bka das bundeskriminalamt mit
unterstützung der brandenburgischen
landespolizei in neuhardenberg zu einer
lagerhalle gefahren die auf einem
gelände auf einem landwirtschaftlich
genutzten gelände liegt die sind große
lagerhallen die wird getreide getrocknet
normalerweise aber die leute sagten mir
dass wenn nicht gerade die ernte
eingefahren wird und diese silos
verladen wird oder diese
trocknungsanlagen dann ist hier
wochenlang überhaupt nichts los und
hinter mir sieht man einen funkwagen
stehen und diese halle und das ist eine
halle wo früher im traktoren und und
landwirtschaftsmaschinen repariert
worden sind die steht jetzt leer und in
diese halle die wurde offensichtlich
genutzt um hier rauschgift zu handeln zu
lagern und zwischen zu
sortieren um sie dann eben von hier von
diesem völlig abgelegenen ort nach
berlin oder eben an die kunden zu
transportieren
dieser ort ist wirklich völlig abgelegen
man sieht hier dreck man sieht hier müll
unrat autoreifen liegen hier um
gegenüber ist das alte heizkraftwerk der
lpg der landwirtschaftlichen
produktionsgenossenschaft eben aus der
ehemaligen ddr und das steht jetzt hier
alles lässt es am ortsausgang test liegt
verkehrsgünstig extrem clever gewählt
es gibt drei straßen hier aus diesem ort
neuhardenberg das ist ein 3000 seelen
nest
hier ist außer ein wunderschönes schloss
nicht viel was aufsehen erregt es ist
also optimal gelegen das ist nordöstlich
von berlin unweit von der polnischen
grenze auch das ist natürlich für leute
die ich böses im schilde führen die
kriminelle energie haben natürlich immer
sehr gut wenn landesgrenzen da sind dann
kann man sich der polizei erstmal
entziehen durch flucht über die grenze
und genau dieser ort liegt eben hier
hinter mir und die polizei und das bka
sind eben daran sich zugang zu dem
objekt zu verschaffen
sie haben mir heute früh das rolltor
aufgebrochen das war alles sehr ruhig
ist es niemand geflohen hier war also
niemand im gebäude und jetzt sind eben
die ermittler vor ort und verschaffen
sich einen überblick was hier in diesem
gebäude tatsächlich noch gelagert ist
und was sie eben noch ein spuren sichern
können
zurzeit ist die feuerwehr hinzu geholt
worden
die eben mit spezialgerät versuchte die
türen aufzumachen und die haben ist
jetzt geschafft die tür ist offen
das gebäude ist also betretbar in gänze
und die ermittler sind jetzt da drin und
sammeln eben alles was hier von den
mietern hier noch übrig gelassen worden
ist um es eben dann eventuell gegen sie
zu verwenden so weit von hier erst mal
aus neuhardenberg dankeschön hannes
rasic live aus brandenburg und wir
wollen jetzt nach berlin-neukölln
schalten denn auch dort wurde heute
morgen in den frühen morgenstunden
zugeschlagen zugegriffen von den beamten
und wie man weiß mehr zu dem einsatz
heute morgen
ja bin ich drauf an dich was heute
passiert wir stehen hier an der
sonnenallee
hier kamen heute morgen gegen 5 uhr 56
sek beamte und stirbt in eine wohnung
und zwar die wohnung von nazareth
das ist ein ja ein mann der schon im
gefängnis saß wegen drogenhandels und
die beamten fanden ihn hier nicht trafen
hier nicht an obwohl er eine fußfessel
trug allerdings wurde der mann offenbar
woanders festgenommen es kam dann leute
mit einem drogenspürhund der zeug haben
hier ein die steuerfahndung kam rein und
interessant ist dass diese immobilie
hinter uns sich zu den immobilien gehört
die vor einigen jahren von der berliner
staatsanwaltschaft eingezogen wurden da
sie offenbar mit illegaler wirtschaft
gewinnen gekauft wurden